soulja boy came through and i asked him
about the name
draco i said hey look man i said i had
draco the ruler up here
this happened today i said uh
i didn't bring up the jail [ __ ] because
i mean i'm you know but i said look i
had draco the rule up here
that's obviously his name he's had that
name for a long time
he's not too fond of you having called
yourself big draco
he said my name is deandre
cortez whatever his last name is so he
said
draco the last three the last three
letters of his first name in the first
two
oh you've heard it before okay okay i'm
just letting you know that that's
he ain't never been there
so you're saying he knows who you are
very aware of yeah okay okay
okay so the draco the ruler and big
draco
collaboration will never happen
i wouldn't oh if he pages
yo the way you just said it and hit the
vape
eight 50 bands right you get the video
in the verse
video you get to look cool you get all
the street [ __ ] that
have actually been in jail in your bag
in the background
he got a record right now you know he
said you know he seemed like he's
at least the last time i saw him was he
when he had was on his uh
the gucci headband wave where he was
talking crazy to everybody
he can ride tick tock right now that's
just you know everybody
but you gotta make it count